il y a deux semaines à stockholm un
dirigeant de bombardier comparaît en
cour
menottes aux poings il est détenu et
soupçonnés de corruption
le procureur de l'unité nationale
anti-corruption de suède crois qu'il a
participé à une vaste manipulation
d'appel d'offres pour permettre à
bombardier transport de décrocher un
contrat public en azerbaïdjan en 2013
un consortium dirigé par bombardier a
obtenu un contrat de 340 millions de
dollars américains financés par la
banque mondiale
l'argent devait servir à la
modernisation du réseau ferroviaire
national
les autorités suédoises croit que
certaines sommes ont été versées en
pots-de-vin et que d'autres dirigeants
de bombardier en suède pourrait être
impliqué selon notre propre enquête
l' affaire aurait plusieurs
ramifications
[Musique]
et cette forme au début février
rencontre avec des collègues de la
télévision publique suédoise et de l'
agence de presse tt
nous consultons des documents qu'ils ont
obtenu deux contrats montrent que
bombardier utilise un mystérieux
intermédiaire pour fournir de
l'équipement en azerbaïdjan pour ce
projet la filiale suédoise de bombardier
doit fournir de l'équipement utilisé
dans la signalisation ferroviaire à une
autre filiale en russie
mais selon les deux contrats bombardier
suède ne vend pas ses équipements
directement à bombardier russie la vente
se fait par l'intermédiaire de la
compagnie mardi sur un bond de 6
constitué au royaume uni mais dont on
sait bien peu de choses sur ses
propriétaires dans un premier contrat
bombardier en suède devant les
équipements de signalisation pour les 46
gares amortisseurs pour environ 19
millions de dollars américains monti sur
revendre ensuite les mêmes équipements à
bombardier en russie pour plus de 104
millions une différence de 85 millions
la dernière moins que j'ai quelques
pistes est vraiment les 46 même station
doit être de retour à montréal
nous avons passé en revue chaque détail
des deux contrats gare par gare
avec un expert en enquête de fraude
quand qu'on garde et de contre on sera
content qu'il n'y a pas de changement
des deux donc s'il explique
économiquement comment ça se fait qu'on
se retrouve avec deux contre deux deux
de contrôles identiques donc noté sud
semble pas avoir fait grand chose là
dedans alors c'est pourtant mon tissu
qui touchent le plus gros de l'argent
le 85 millions je m'explique mal pour le
moment s'il faut comprendre c'est que
bombardier se retrouve aux deux bouts de
la transaction avec cette transaction
l'eau il laisserait donc sur la table
85 millions
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une montée seule va bien pu
faire pour récolter 85 millions $ dans
ses transactions vont partiez a déjà
indiqué à nos collègues que monty
s'occupait entre autres de la logistique
de livraison
le keeper company côte
maurice heures au bar sis à leur adresse
de londres aucune trace de bureau de mme
thyssen ni d'employés
en parcourant les panama peppers
on découvre que pendant que menti sur
achète de l'équipement de bombardier en
suède
elle signe un contrat intrigant avec une
société des îles vierges britanniques
brembo management pour exactement le
même équipement on y retrouve 13 gars
qui font partie des 46 apparaissant au
contrat signé avec bombardier
[Musique]
mais si rimbaud fourni les mêmes gendt
et donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un des 2
contre les deux types de documents qui
étaient faux un type de document il faut
mais en tout cas ils peuvent pas
cohabiter dans l'impossibilité
impossible
quand on regarde l'échéancier des
paiements de toutes ces transactions
on commence à voir l'utilité possible de
ce contrat avec mambo en avril 2014
mauritius doit toucher une avance de 23
millions de dollars de la filiale de
bombardier en russie à deux semaines
d'intervalle
monfils ruff s'engage à payer la même
somme à rimbaud management ça veut donc
dire que le profil reste pas dans notre
soeur du tessin dans rambo rainbow est
aux îles vierges britanniques taux
d'imposition quasi nul sinon nous pour
les entreprises off shore sade
intéressant d'envoyer un profit dans
cette compagnie là ça ne s'arrête pas là
on a découvert que presque simultanément
une autre société écran jean louis freyd
dont les propriétaires sont au belize
doit recevoir à son tour 15 points 8
millions de rimbaud
à stockholm le procureur de l'unité
anticorruption crois que menti sur a
servi à verser des pots de maints
projets en azerbaïdjan dans des
courriels de bombardier déposés en cour
des employés de bombardier décrivent
menthe et sauve comme une coquille sans
aucune activité réelle un véhicule pour
détourner de l'argent public vers des
poches privées
[Musique]
là qui est allé l'argent que menti sur à
verser à rebours management à londres
notre collègue russe au les 6h makoun
nous aide à comprendre qui se cache
derrière rumbo et dans les documents
avec lesquels on travaille on voit
plusieurs signes de alexei cracovie -
alexei camping alexis cabine et le
propriétaire de rimbaud mais on retrouve
aussi sa trace dans une entreprise de
bombardier aux pays bas qui elle même
est actionnaire d'une firme de
l'industrie ferroviaire en russie
aujourd'hui
audacia va rencontrer des remèdes
bourdonne sauf un ancien banquier russe
qui s'est exilé à londres par crainte de
représailles de ses anciens partenaires
d'affaires en 2012
il ad'ailleurs survécu à un attentat en
angleterre
il est important parce qu'il connaît
bien toutes ces personnes sur qui on
enquête présente aujourd'hui il accepte
de rencontrer au les siens mais sans
caméras
voici ce qu'il pense de la transaction
entre multiserv et rainbow
ça ressemble à un prétexte des plus
stupides pour transférer de l'argent il
ya longtemps tout le monde faisait ça
sans se faire prendre
ces vieux jeu c'est digne des hommes des
cavernes
documenter ce qui se cache derrière tout
cela sera le fruit d'un travail d'équipé
notre groupe de journalistes a découvert
que la société mère de marc thiessen a
été appliquée dans des transactions de
millions de dollars avec alexis cabine
[Musique]
on voit ce système compliqué de près
avec de l'argent qu'ils aillent qui via
une compagnie à l'autre pour mal compris
le truc empreintes ou blanchiment
d'argent au risque là j'ai postulé
criminalité dans ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que pour par exemple
l'organisation d'application des lois
fiscales
si on rajoute des couches plus c'est
compliqué pour les organisations devenez
percer ses coaches l'or dans les
documents saisis chez bombardier par la
justice suédoise
avec ses hits rabin est décrit comme
faisant partie de petits groupes de
personnes influentes qui ont accès à
presque tous les dirigeants de
compagnies de chemin de fer de l'ex urss
avec de tels contacts ils peuvent
influencer les décisions influencer les
décisions
c'est justement ce que l'unité
anticorruption suédoise crois que
bombardier a pu faire en azerbaïdjan ils
ont eu plusieurs rencontres non
officielle avec des représentants avant
même que ne débute le processus d'appel
d'offres ils se sont entendus sur les
critères pour la solution technique pour
l'autorité ferroviaire de l'azerbaïdjan
afin que bombardier remporte le contrat
plus facile bombarde ici c'est pas un
organisme à but non lucratif et si on
prend pour hypothèse également le quai
fictive à lui aucune raison économique
de laisser 85 millions dans un hôtel st
ça pourrait ça pourrait être également
l'eau un stratagème pour remettre
l'argent des gens qu'ils ont déjeuné
déjà donné des contrôles dont celle ci
pourrait être la corruption de gamme
par communiqué bombardier affirme
qu'elle a remporté le contrat en
azerbaïdjan après un appel d'offres
ouvert et équitable
ce ne serait pas la seule faveur à
laquelle aurait consenti les dirigeants
de bombardier en suède pour remporter
l'appel d'offres en plus du stratagème
d'amortisseur
selon le procureur il aurait même
accepté qu'une compagnie de
l'azerbaïdjan
sans expérience dans le domaine 30
signal rabita soit partenaire dans le
projet et la personne derrière cette
compagnie de l'azerbaïdjan votre
compréhension c'est que ce serait
quelqu'un des autorités en azerbaïdjan
oui et c'est le bon côté pour lui parce
qu'à la fin ils auront généré des
revenus et les contacts de notre
collègue bosniaque miranda pas trop
cheap nous aident à en apprendre un peu
plus sur cette compagnie à bakou en
azerbaïdjan le siège social se trouve
dans cet immeuble à logements à la porte
de l'appartement censé être l'adresse de
la compagnie aucune trace que la
présence de transe signal rabita un
collaborateur de miranda s'est rendu
près de la frontière de l'iran dans le
petit village de fusil 10 ou habiterait
le propriétaire de la compagnie
celui qui selon nos informations est le
propriétaire de tran signal rabita
demeure ici il s'agit d'un électricien
qui dit ne rien connaître de ce que fait
cette compagnie ni ici ni à bas coûts
personne n'a pu nous éclairer sur 36
nian rabita tous à alès bien des
questions pour lesquelles nous espérions
des réponses de bombardier notre
collègue yoakim deux marques a tenté
d'en parler un des patrons en suède
tomasz by mr d être forte au rôle merde
sol il a reconnu sa signature sur un
document mais il a refusé d'en dire plus
de 100 network à la banque mondiale ou
s'ils se pose des questions sur ce qui
se passe en azerbaïdjan elle a entrepris
une vérification en 2013 la banque a
accordé un financement supplémentaire de
220 millions de dollars au projet en
azerbaïdjan en grande partie pour payer
les frais pour la signalisation les 85
millions partie d'un bâtisseur
représente plus du tiers de cette somme
bombardier dit prendre l'affairé très au
sérieux et collaborer avec les autorités
la compagnie ajoute qu'elle ne dispose
d'aucune information relative à quelques
comportement illégal que ce soit et
qu'elle prendra les mesures nécessaires
si elle en découvre
à stockholm l'avocate du dirigeant russe
de bombardier arrêté en suède dit que
son client nie les allégations faites
contre lui par la justice suédoise
de son côté le procureur forsberg se
concentre présentement sur le contrat en
azerbaïdjan mais pour la suite de son
enquête il ne ferme aucune porte
ce n'est pas inhabituel dans ce genre d'
enquête qu'on puisse découvrir de
nouveaux soupçons ou allégations qui
pourrait nous mener à ouvrir une autre
enquête en décembre dernier le quotidien
the globe and mail a révélé que
bombardier a aussi utilisé la société
écran multiserv en russie nos collègues
suédois ont de plus obtenu ce contrat
concernant la mongolie daté de février
2016 qui montre que menti sur faisait
encore partie des plans de bombardier
jusqu'à récemment dans ce cas comme dans
beaucoup d'autres la piste commence ici
en suède s'est aussi dit si qu'un début
telle enquête policière suédoise dont
personne ne peut prédire pour l'instant
jusqu'où elle ira